all right let's get to the Friday mail
bag where you can write to me and
sometimes it'll appear on the show you
can email info davidpackman.com
ideally with a substantive commentary
but sometimes there is very little
substance and that's okay I want to
start today with an email from a right
winger I think
who thinks they're on to me they think
they know my trick take a look at this
message Andrew wrote to me and said it's
a nice trick
good afternoon sir
I noticed that you only discussed the
dumbest or the dumb Republicans on your
show it's a nice trick it's the same
trick Tucker and Sean Hannity and Don
Lemon and many others use you will find
no shortage of idiots on both sides of
the aisle and what you do is shine a
light on just those people
do you ever plan on having a
conversation with anyone that you can't
tip the outcome in your favor if your
arguments are so good you should be able
to talk to anyone not just the pillow
guy and Jesse Lee Peterson or whatever
his name is I read the comments your
audience writes and I must say that the
most ignorant that they the most
ignorant and misinborn people in America
and what's scary is that these people
think they are the Smart Ones I don't
even do this for a living and I can pick
apart every single one of your arguments
or at least show where you are being a
hypocrite I honestly used to really like
you I know
I like to hear solid arguments from both
sides but now I realize you are just a
fraud I might as well call you Hannity
Jr it's the same Playbook bro you know
we've so first of all they never tell
you who the smart conservatives are tell
me exactly who they are because Lego
well Ben Shapiro
I interviewed Ben Shapiro on the show
it didn't go great for him it wasn't
like terribly humiliating but he didn't
make a lot of sense
and then he's refused all subsequent
invitations
I've had Michael Knowles on the show
some of these right-wingers go Knowles
is the smart one
to the extent that Jordan Peterson is a
right-winger people say well but
Peterson's been on and he has an open
invitation we tried to get him back on
recently uh we had Andrew Sullivan on
he's a right winger and I find him to be
intelligent and then no those aren't the
right smart right-wingers or they're
they're not really right-wingers or we
we interview all sorts of people okay
all sorts of people this is a very
boring criticism
let's go next to Earl now I'm going to
be totally honest with you
I don't know if this email from Earl is
satire
Earl wrote in about raising the minimum
wage and said I am so disappointed to
see encouragement from your people to
raise the minimum wage to 15 an hour
this could destroy capitalism as we know
it forcing millions of businesses and
CEOs out of work because people are too
lazy to work and too stupid to budget I
am not an economist like Thomas Sowell
but I can do simple math so let's start
725 an hour is 290 a week that's fifteen
thousand eighty dollars for the year
average health insurance is only 150 a
week that's 600 a month average
apartment rent for a one bedroom is only
275 a week that's 1100 a month average
food costs for one person is only 51 a
week average Transportation 65 a week
utility bills 35 a week
so to survive we don't need a 15 per
hour minimum wage all the person has to
do is work two full-time jobs and drive
Uber in their spare time I'm sure that's
what Milton Friedman or Thomas Sowell
would do
if this is satire it's very well done
um if it's not then it's kind of weird
but I think because I can't tell I'll do
it as a presented without comment
John wrote In
John says hi David huge fan of the show
was excited to find for you to find
another right winger to interview this
week with John T Smithy
I think he was I think it was John
Teague as a tool for your viewers to
understand when confronted with the new
IRS hiring goals that 87 000 number
often thrown around is misleading this
is really important because
right-wingers are loving this talking
point of why does Joe Biden need 87 000
more IRS agents well John explains first
of all it's based on a proposal from May
2021 and not actually relevant to the
current plan number two the IRS expects
55 000 retirees in the next 10 years
these new agents would replace those
folks three the new hiring quota would
be over 10 years rather than immediately
you know that does change
the big picture of that IRS hiring
doesn't it John writes I'm a CPA who has
had this discussion multiple times a
week with clients and I've got to tell
you they look really dumb when I turn
this around on them well John I always
appreciate more information and John
does seem to know exactly what he's
talking about I'll keep that in mind
when they pull the IRS talking points
glorious Taco wrote in saying shouldn't
Abbott and DeSantis be arrested for
those immigrant buses David in the past
couple months Abbott and DeSantis have
been sending busloads of illegal
immigrants to various Northeast
democratic-run cities claiming that
illegal immigration needs to be dealt
with now shouldn't these two be arrested
for knowingly transporting illegal
aliens across state lines a federal
crime and what money is being used to
fund these trips if public funds should
that be another federal crime yeah we
talked about this on Monday
NPR has a really good article about the
possible illegality of the DeSantis
migrant Martha's Vineyard stunt I don't
want to rehash everything I said you can
check out that clip but GT you are spot
on in identifying there are a bunch of
possible crimes there a bunch of
possible crimes
Anthony wrote in about Michael Cohen
Trump's former lawyer and says hey David
I'm not sure if you addressed this
before but I've been listening to the
Michael Cohen podcast and I noticed a
couple times that he referenced you as
the guy that goes to Trump rallies and
talks to Trump supporters I don't think
he has the right guy unless you've been
out there in which I'm sorry I even
addressed this I thought maybe he was
thinking of Jordan klepper or some other
mockery type journals yeah so Michael
Michael Cohen's great guy were in touch
and he's a supporter of the show we're
gonna have him back on soon I like
Michael Cohen
he sometimes refers to me as a comedian
which I'm glad to be called although I'm
about to show you a voice an email that
says I'm not funny but to the extent
that Michael Coleman finds me funny I'm
glad for him to call me a comedian
Michael Cohen has also said the guy that
goes to Trump rallies and when Michael
Cohen interviewed legal analyst Asha
rangappa Asha also said I'm the guy that
goes to the Trump rallies so we've sent
people to Trump rallies we will also
sometimes look at clips from Trump
rallies I don't know where it all came
from your guess is as good as mine
um but I know exactly what you're
talking about
humor here is someone who doesn't like
my humor or says I'm not funny
like the show a lot Dave
but find your humor a bit lacking not a
complaint at all but the dim sum word
with bobert cracked me up she's in my
district as Peter's in Mesa County
trial date for Peters that was just set
is six months from now no lack of loons
around here very much appreciate your
efforts uh says Tom you know
does it make sense to say that my humor
is lacking when it's not a comedy show I
don't I don't know I mean it's sort of
like if you said I didn't like uh what's
a really like hard-boiled
TV show it's kind of dark
I don't know there's this there's
actually a really good German uh time
travel show called dark and it is a dark
show
it would be weird to say now the humor
is lacking it's not a comedy series so I
just don't know about this my humor is
lacking it's not really meant to be a
comedy show so I don't know let me know
what you think about what Tom has to say
Mike in New York City also wrote In Mike
said David I always found it hilarious
that Maga people think they're being
clever by saying let's go Brandon and
that they think this bothers anyone on
the left at all I think democrats should
Co-op you mean co-opt should co-opt the
phrase let's go Brandon they should
start chanting it in support every time
Biden does something good yeah I that
would be funny you know a lot of times
taking back the phrase is kind of silly
in this case I think it would be funny
for the left to also start using let's
go Brandon as a positive one of the
cringiest things is when these right
Wingers you can you see them and you can
they think they're so smart and clever
and incisive when they go let's go
Brandon and some of them email me
and they'll say David can you tell
Brandon to pay attention to his
teleprompter or whatever you know that
type of thing
and they genuinely think they're being
super clever it's cringy the entire
let's go Brandon thing is one of the
cringiest out there and the funniest
part of it is how clever they think they
are they will never change at least it
doesn't seem like it anytime soon make
sure you were signed up for our bonus
show
oh my clip isn't even playing
that was weird it like came out of the
wrong speaker anyway you know Alex Jones
doesn't like the bonus show just
remember that to me that's a great
endorsement of the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
and get instant access to that very same
bonus show we've got one coming up today
right after the podcast